foreign
next course is called memory and that is
what is meant to evoke
a memory so let me tell you a memory of
mine when I was growing up a child in
Waterloo Iowa Tuesday was taco night oh
yeah Taco Tuesday
and this here this lady here this is my
mother
as you can see she's rather drunk This
Is Not Unusual
when I was seven years old one Tuesday
my father came home quite drunk
really drunk
also not unusual
my mother grew angry and screamed at him
at which point he proceeded to wrap a
telephone cord around her neck and pull
it tight
I wept
I screamed and begged him to stop
to make him stop
but I finally had to stab him in the
thigh with kitchen scissors
you remember that mother don't you
suppose I should have stabbed him in the
throat that evening
but we're not so smart When We're Young
it was as you can imagine is a very
memorable taco night
I've been cutting in
I love it you liked it it's a backstory
to what makes him a chef artists
thank you
so
here you have
house smoked breast chicken thigh al
pastor and our own tortillas made with
heirloom Master one of Hawthorne's
signature dishes
we change our menu constantly but as
Miss Bloom knows this has been a staple
since day one
it's uh what you once said put you on
the map put me on the map precisely what
map would that be
I wonder anyways because we're always
innovating and we fear irrelevance
an update to a classic the images on the
tortillas have been made using a laser
engraving machine it's the first time
we've used it
we hope this taco night evokes strong
memories for us all enjoy
and of course he had to do a taco
there you are
what are they well they're restaurants
um
that I reviewed that all closed oh
like a gag then
um I think so
Richard what are these
Taco things for the tacos no the
pictures they're they're all of us
huh wow
this one is after you had the melanoma
removed from your forehead there's the
bandage isn't that nice they remembered
us
Tyler is that you
they're on me from tonight taking photos
I knew it he hates me I mean I didn't
think he'd really mind that should I
apologize apologize for what oh
call him Dr sunshine
oh my God I forgot
dumb part bad script Fun Shoot though
maybe it's a joke because you're friends
right
friends
I mean you know do I have any friends
um
are these
how do they get these
it's not good
uh excuse me
can I help you soon yeah what
the hell are these these are tortillas
tortillas so what are these
these are tortillas which contain
echobright's tax records and other
documents showing how your company has
created invoices with fake charges
how did you get these I'm sorry but Chef
never Reveals His recipes
do you know how you are
wow this place close by the morning do
you understand
oh no that won't be necessary
enjoy
and this is you
who is that woman
uh
well how the hell should I know it's
faked it's some sort of sort of
stupid joke it's a taco okay can't hurt
you yeah Taco that might hold up in corn
we have plausible deniability and
if they try to turn Us in right if they
turn us then they'd be turning barricade
and then maybe just as we are right so
we're fine
right
yeah we're fine okay you can't take your
photography I think okay I have to make
this right somehow I have to well I'll
tell you how you make it right you send
it back excuse me excuse me sir hi
back to this kitchen
what did you just call me I called you a
child
Tyler you need to apologize to me right
now you cannot speak to me that way
actually I can because ding dong I'm the
one who's paying so maybe shut up and
eat
oh my God
oh my God
this is incredible you have to try this
no thanks don't let me interrupt
foreign
how can I assist you
just looking for the ladies room right
this way
thank you
what's behind that silver door
something very special
[Music]